I took technologies that already exist
and just combined them in a way that
nobody had really thought of because we
had this realization of what the ideal
form of nanofabrication might be and we
surveyed the landscape for what existed
and what we could use and then put them
together and as it turns out that
involved taking elements from by a
biological engineering all the
conjugation chemistry's it involved
taking this new form of microscopy that
edie headed and his students had
invented expansion microscopy as well as
these new ways of doing lithography in
three dimensions which came out of
initially biological imaging but then
started getting applied to nano
fabrication as well so you know no one
of those disciplines on its own could
have done it right it's it's really how
things collide to create something
entirely new boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Alex
Akiane we are on site at MIT Media Lab
in Cambridge Massachusetts we are going
to be talking about light art nanotech
we have Daniel Iran joining us on the
show hello hello how are you thank you
so much for coming on really appreciate
it very grateful that CERN Uche bump
Canova introduced us and we are gonna be
unpacking a lot of great technical
nuance and meter work and also
applications of it it was mind-blowing
for me trying to understand it in the
short time that we had before this for
those that don't know dance background
he's a PhD student at MIT Media Lab in
the synthetic neurobiology group he's an
artist scientist and inventor who
creates using boat light both
aesthetically and technically and you
can find his website link below iranian
art comm as well as his MIT Media Lab
profile link alright Dan let's start
things off with our question that we
like asking that we find ourselves as
stewards of Earth what is your current
take on the state of humanity well I
think I'm generally pretty optimistic
about
things the trend line for Prosperity is
just been going up steadily for a long
time and that has not changed there's
definitely a lot of reasons for concern
about the future and even about the
present but overall I think you know
humanity will step up to the challenge
and be able to address it so long as
we're willing and able to really focus
and answer and tackle hard issues that
are in front of us yes yes yeah totes
there's a lot to tack when we got to
come together yeah there's a lot go all
the issue here is the coming together
bit because somehow the technologies
that connected us much more have somehow
also fractured us much more in some ways
get the double edginess of it yeah
now let's hit your let's hit your
journey so Indiana born and then
Massachusetts raised that's right and
then how did you pick up your interest
in light and art well it all started
quite a long time ago in about middle
school I started working in a darkroom
and I just had some amazing mentors all
through middle school and then high
school and I just fell in love with that
process of taking imagery capturing
light and then placing a piece of paper
in chemicals and just watching an image
appear so that initially is what really
made me fall in love with light yeah and
that process is so interestingly you
know 200 years ago photography came to
came to life and then all the way up to
actually leaving the the photo in
chemicals and having it appear slowly
for you that was very profound for you
and now all the way to us having the
cameras in our pockets it's been a huge
qj1 you know we both got into witness
yes so many digital photos now taken
every single day now when when that aha
moment you know sparked for you what was
what was your feeling about about light
and art when you saw that image appear I
think it was just astonishment that you
could take something a moment from your
everyday life and then just fix it and
make it permanent right and what's I
think powerful there is the
recontextualizing of an experience right
being able to take something that you
imagined and then saw and translate that
through technology and with your mind's
eye to create an aesthetic or idea and
communicate that to others yes all
through light in one and chemistry any
way or another you now through also
other forms of technology but I love how
you put it like a pressing a pause
button on a frame yeah reality and then
being able to kind of relive that if you
want and in a in the 2d at least the
representation and eventually hopefully
in a complete virtual immersion
potentially maybe that would be that
would be nuts
now this kind of led you to a radiant
art and you've been doing that for eight
years yeah teach us about a radiant
heart well I would say when I started
going into college I became I wouldn't
say bored with but like disinterested in
doing photography which is purely
representational anymore and I really
fell in love more purely with this idea
of art and trying to create things using
light and make artworks that are made of
nothing other than light and that sort
of led me on a path where I started
studying all the old photographic
processes and masters and how they how
it was both an act of like science as
well as an act of art and that they
needed to know what they were doing they
need
to manipulate things chemically as well
as with light and with the technology of
the cameras themselves and it was it was
I feel like well the first medium where
technology became intrinsic to you know
the aesthetic yeah there's something
very profound about like you said
capturing these these are called
irradiance you call coherent light
you're doing an aesthetic investigation
to the wave nature of light yeah these
are gorgeous images of coherent light
you actually have one right there on on
your laptop you know it right like this
yes and and this is this is super
gorgeous and I want you to you know
explain this to us and we'll have some
of these embedded as you talk yeah so
teach us about about it so I was really
inspired to do this project
almost serendipitously actually I was
learning a little bit about holography
and I had been working in some of these
optical applications for calligraphy and
I just started noticing you know when
you messed things up sometimes you get
these really crazy forms of light just
scattering out across the room so
instead of trying to make Holograms I
instead started trying to capture those
artifacts and the way I ended up making
these is I actually would make optical
elements I blow these small glass pieces
that mangle and manipulate and refract
the light quite a lot and then by
passing a beam of coherent light through
it I could then capture those images
directly onto film but what's most
interesting is that in using coherent
light it actually exposes the wave
nature of the light because you can
actually see the interactions of the
waves just like you might see ripples on
a pond overlapping to create textures of
like cross hatching and and things like
that so you actually get to see that
within the imagery
itself and then how are you capturing
this how are these photons kind of just
so there's these are photons coming at
each other but they're being projected
onto a plane and that plane is actually
a very large piece of film so there's no
camera but rather light just projected
directly on to film that is kind of
crashing into each other like a boy and
they're causing yeah yeah yeah so the
waves are doing that throughout the
whole space and I'm just taking like one
slice one slice out of that yeah and how
do you capture that again I just use the
same sort of film that's used in the old
old view cameras the ones where you put
like a hood over your head where there's
like there's a slider that comes up
yeah well all I do is I compose what I
want onto a piece of paper essentially
and I replace that with the film holder
and then open it up and make a brief
exposure brief exposure interesting
interesting okay okay yeah that this
this type of it's your you're taking
what I think so many of us forget about
like the environments that were in have
light being exposed like in this room
all the time and they're flying around
enabling us this yeah and a little bit
more than that also you know the Wi-Fi
that's also electromagnetic radiation
and you know these sorts of forms of
waves overlapping and interfering with
one another are happening all around us
even though we can't see it and would
you say that then they're waves of
things like a Wi-Fi and like the photons
are they kind of just like constantly
interests are there all the time in the
spaces so within the oxygen and nitrogen
that's here there's also all the waves
of photons and Wi-Fi and and then we're
just as animals just sitting and yeah
yeah we're just being bombarded oh yeah
yeah so if you would capture a like kind
of like a still of what you know of what
it looks like would it just look like
this like noise kind of how would it
well I mean most of the radio
we're exposed to is incoherent so it
those waves are there but there's so
many of them and they're not lined up so
it all just looks like blurs together
but it's still happening whereas with a
laser beam what you've done is you've
lined all those waves up so that when
they do interact you can actually see
these sorts of interference patterns
occurring yeah interesting so you could
almost think about it that like directly
from the source of light it's the most
coherent and then it becomes incoherent
once it gets mixed up with all the
others a little bit I mean most of these
lights are incoherent to begin with it
really takes you know a laser laser yeah
a laser to be able to do that yeah and
then and then is that the difference
then between a coherent is a
constructive yeah coherent means that
all the waves are lined up or all the
waves are lined up and then the DC and
that's a constructive interference or
its destructive interfere so that's when
you you let's say you have those waves
and you overlap them sometimes those
waves will add together and make a
bigger peak or sometimes they'll cancel
out and there'll be nothing there okay
okay so if the wave is propagated right
next right on top of potentially another
wave you can get the bigger peaks and
that if they're if they're behind SATA
level bed then it could occur solo okay
okay oftentimes when you do this you see
both you see them both cancelling out
and creating brighter Peaks which is why
you see like these big ripples
especially when two waves come together
in water and you get bigger they get
taller yep then in some areas you don't
see anything it's just sort of flat yeah
interesting so that may be like when in
the ocean maybe to like you know ten
foot waves kind of like come together
and I get you in exactly that would be
constructive constructive interference
interesting versus when they kind of
cause each other to break apart and do
that destructive interesting okay so
taking us all the way to MIT Media Lab
the last four years here you're pursuing
her PhD in the synthetic neurobiology
group
and you're exploring nanotechnology
you're blowing open the design
constraints for nano fabrication with
what's known as implosion fabrication so
teach us about that it's like you were
you were blowing my mind with this like
to 2d Nanofab predicated on the planar
on a single plane versus 3d nano fat
predicated on a volumetric deposition
yeah that's right so this project
started quite a long time ago and what
actually happened is I had been in
photography for doing that
professionally just doing creating art
and trying to show it and things like
that and then I reconnected actually
with my high school friend Samuel
Rodriguez so I started this project with
and he invited me to the lab and
introduced me to Ed and had started
letting me just start working in a dark
in the Leppa and the wet lab around
there so it's worth like made this
transition from darkroom to wet lab and
in that process we ended up having this
insight which is based off of another
technology from the lab called expansion
microscopy which was at the time a crazy
idea that you can take a tissue and in
order to see it with better resolution
you actually just make it bigger as
opposed to trying to build fancier and
fancier microscopes to try to see below
the diffraction limit of light and as it
turns out this works great and I demoed
that on the Ted stage with the diaper
them yes that's right for the same
polymer as in diapers and so excessively
microscopy is when you blow something up
- that's smaller blow it up to make it
easier for you to analyze and and do a
photographic yeah image images yeah so
and then this was initially just sort of
a thought experiment about okay what if
you did that in Reverse right what if
instead of taking something you want to
see and making it bigger why don't you
take something and pattern it bigger and
then make it smaller
and more importantly what's that even
good for right
this crazy idea of shrinking things down
but what we've realized is this actually
has quite a lot of benefits even beyond
the shrink itself because there's an
analogue here between what
nanofabrication was and what it could be
in the future in that once you have this
scaffold like the one in expansion
microscopy what you can do is you can
create things in a volume right as
opposed to having to have it all
connected or anything like that
so whereas nano fabrication was
predicated on a planar deposition where
you create a mask and then you deposit
material and then you do that over and
over again to build something we're
taking what was an imaging technology
for imaging and three dimensions turning
that on its head to do patterning which
people have already done but more
importantly doing it inside of one of
these scaffolds that lets you shrink it
down so it's a bit like the difference
between like a paper cutout and a
painting it for but in 3d whereas in 2d
and if you want to make a painting you
have this canvas and this is a bit like
a two-dimensional SCAF going to say yeah
and you can apply different amounts of
paint so you can create gradients the
paint doesn't need to be connected to
each other it can be separate from one
another and you can put down different
colors and that's almost like putting
down different materials whereas with a
paper cutout you sort of have to have
everything connected together it's sort
of hard to have like multiple different
materials you have to be like actually
going in and grafting it together so
it's supporting and connected so we
wanted to do that for the third
dimension and that brought us to this
idea of volumetric deposition whereas
when we make transistors we rely on
something called the planar process
which is planar deposition so in order
to extend that into the third dimension
we have this scaffold to be able to do
volumetric deposition and then to teach
us about the actual scaffold there's a
hydrogel yeah I've all teach yet so
teachers but in that house
you can sort of think of it as a bowl of
spaghetti in water where all the
spaghetti is sort of connected to each
other in this big Network and in the
case of this hydrogel that spaghetti has
a whole bunch of different chemical
groups on it that are negatively charged
so they repel each other so that's what
causes it to expand and like holds that
open right and then you can infuse a
small dye actually and then wherever you
zap that with light it'll stick to the
spaghetti and that forms an anchor
actually is a bit like a latent image in
photography where you've you create this
initial image in three dimensions and
then what you can do is go in afterwards
and develop it into whatever material
you want through volumetric deposition
okay and then when as I'm as I'm you
you're eight you're the anchor points
are then you're attaching your shiny
light so so it attached attaches and
then afterwards we can deposit on those
anchor points yes using nano particles
or other water-based chemistry where you
just sort of like wash something on and
it either sticks or then grows at the
point where you've put all these anchors
and what would be an example of a
material that you would want to anchor
on to so the ones we've demonstrated are
silver for making conductors and
semiconducting nano crystals as well so
and then because we're again using this
expansion microscopy hydrogel you can
then actually add acid or salt and then
it shrinks down by a factor of ten or
more actually linearly which is you know
we can go as much as a million fold
volumetric Wow
and once you've finished with that
process it's actually dehydrated so it's
actually a resistor it's like a
dielectric material which you now have
conductors and potentially also
semiconductors and
at it inside of holy cow yeah Wow okay
so let me see let me see if I can
paraphrase can so you have like a bowl
of interconnected spaghetti in water and
then you have the that the the egg
hydrogel enables you to add the anchor
points and shine the material the dye is
dye when you pattern it it creates those
anchor points the dye creates the anchor
yeah that sticks to the spaghetti it's
tonight and that's like an intermediate
that then lets you put other material so
it's like a meatball then can stick to
it
sure sure and then when you remove all
the water exactly come to a new used
acid or salt yes okay and then that can
shrink it by 10 or more fold dumps and
potentially even well actually any
amount anywhere 'fl from between 2 to
now even like 44 so are we're talking
like taking like a bowl like an actual
bowl spaghetti and turning that into
like less than a grain of sand
oh yeah exactly yeah and then you can
embed potentially computational capacity
into that something that's less than a
grain of sand absolutely and then is
that mostly like seeming to be used for
computational purposes well I think
there's many many different applications
here you can take it in so many
different directions since really what
we've done is just expand the design
space for what can be made to have nano
scale resolution and also useful
materials right so as a result there's
lots of things you can do you could make
traditional computers potentially the
things I'm most excited about are the
light based applications so 3d printing
optics lenses that are super super thin
but very powerful or even it's been
shown you can make these optical neural
networks so we could patter an optical
neural networks and then you know if you
expend that even further you could
imagine maybe even making minds that
function based off of light okay before
we eats all those things yeah how do we
actually make that both spaghetti into
like something that's like
optic I loved it yeah how would you well
in this case the thing you're causing to
stick to the backbone of the hydrogel is
something that causes light to bend so
you just control either the geometry of
where you put the material that causes
light to bend or the concentration
because you can also just change the
laser intensity when you're trying to
pattern it and you can control how much
of it it is and that's called a gradient
optic actually yeah which traditionally
have been very very hard to make and you
never really had much geometric control
but now we have essentially complete
geometric control okay and then with
this complete geometric control you're
able to add at whatever it may be for
processing capacity or for optical
capacity to them and then you're
shrinking it and you're looking to add
other materials you're looking to see if
this can be used for you said crazy
things like the optics computation also
you said what would you said of photonic
computing optical neural networks minds
made out of light
okay let's unpack these one at a time so
what would what would a what would a
something that's at the nano scale of an
optic how would that yet be used how
would that be used so one simple case is
just making lenses that are much smaller
and much better you know when you stick
a lens on your camera it's you know
sometimes this long you know sometimes
even this long right but there's the
only reason it needs to be that long is
you need to have like the curvature of
the lens and it needs to be of a certain
size to be able to collect that light
but each one of those lenses induces
certain kinds of aberrations so then you
need more lenses to correct for those in
order to shape and sculpt the light to
be just right once it like hits your
sensor or a piece of film but when you
have this sort of nano scale control and
these materials that can bend like quite
a lot
you can then architect all those
functions from all those different lens
elements all into one very
very thin plain okay so the amount of
yes space that we need in order to have
the optic make the capturing of the
image and then that we could embed the
ability to be able to maybe send that
constant stream of what you're capturing
- yeah - are yeah you could do that with
you know electronics for capturing it at
the back you could also one of the
cooler papers that came out recently is
they actually 3d printed these grids
that diffract light in different ways
and they have multiple layers of them
and each layer is actually the layer and
a neural network so each layer is doing
computation on that light so you can cup
sensors on this side and then an object
on the other side and it'll do the
machine vision to say is that a Chu Wow
Wow
with it so within the actual optical
image that was done with microwaves so
much longer wavelengths but I could do
that with optical wavelengths the
visible spectrum which is how we view
the world so maybe also how we want
these things to understand the world
whoa okay so we're so we're talking
things have been at the at the nano
scale almost nano scale is invisible to
the human eye absolutely yes yeah so
about the smallest thing a human eye can
see is roughly I think 10 microns with
if you just hit catch the light just
right and this is let's see about three
orders of magnitude less than that three
orders me a little more than that it's a
billionth of a meter it's 10 to the
negative 9 yeah okay yeah okay yeah yeah
so so then so then when you embed this
thing that these nano texts that are you
know basically you know invisible they
are invisible to the human eye then I'm
so crazy to think for for us animals
that you can somehow put optical
technology processing technology
embedded into something that's that
small when we've had these massive
computers that yeah then we've gotten a
lot smaller it's crazy in some senses
but you look at biology and it's already
doing all that sort of stuff so this is
not new it's just that we you know with
our big hands fumbling around can't
build it right so we're finally being
able to understand how to manipulate
matter to a greater and greater degree
so we're starting to actually be able to
do some of the same things that biology
can I think that's actually one of the
really exciting things about maybe now
having a rapid prototyping approach to
doing nano fabrication is you can maybe
even have some sort of synthetic
evolution where you can create you know
tens of thousands or millions of
variations on a structure very very
quickly and like in evolution naturally
or it as in this case I guess
unnaturally select for the ones that
work the best and just keep doing that
so you can instead of trying to you know
understand everything and optimize it to
be perfect and our heads are in our
computers instead impose the design
constraints for the function that we
want and then just sort of like guide
the formation of the structures that are
best able to do that yeah that that type
of figuring out what letting the this
directed evolution find the best fit is
and like you said it's already happening
all the booths is the crazy processes
that are happening within our bodies
that we can't necessarily see me in some
ways evolution already happens in our
bodies there's something called somatic
hypermutation which is how our active
immune system works it's actually
actively rejiggering genes to create
antibodies that will recognize whatever
foreign intruders are there and
selecting for the ones that best bind
and then producing more of those in
order to then recognize let's say you
know a bacteria or a virus yep one of
those four say it's likely the confident
constant computing of what's happening
within us in in in regard to the
environments that were in and how to
best survive in them and so then so then
when you when you do a directed
evolution with the like with a synthetic
neurobiology what would that what would
that like look like well it really
depends what you're trying to make right
in the case of like optics for instance
you're talking about creating structures
smaller than the wavelength of light
which performs some operation on that
light so what you could do is you could
just pattern many many variations of
this structure and see how that affects
the light and then you can build like a
catalog of all these things that do
different operations on the light and
then start combining those and seeing
what sort of functions you can create
from that and iterating on that and
maybe all the while taking the
measurements and seeing what these
structures are and using that data to
then do something like machine learning
to then figure out what is the topology
of this space and maybe then more
generatively inside of a computer just
output the function that you care about
just by telling it what you want and
then at the same time not understanding
how any of it Sue's visit does it seem
like the nano fabrication is gonna be
that we're gonna be doing this process
more often with with with the embedding
what we want
optics computing and then shrinking is
that is that that's possible that's
that's one approach to doing it to
getting the resolution is
the shrink but it's unclear that the
real demand here is in resolution rather
just this new expansion of the design
space to be able to create gradients to
be able to pattern multiple materials
and three dimensions and to be able to
do it at really really high resolutions
is incredibly powerful and also in any
single any geometry you can imagine
because it's all embedded in a scaffold
that doesn't need to be connected it
doesn't need to be supported or anything
like that so that really just like blows
things open to some degree and even if
you don't really shrink you could still
use this for doing some very powerful
fabrication and that adding that level
of shrink just lets you get that
resolution down which is good for some
applications this seems to be one of the
many exponential technologies what nano
what nanotech feels like it's going to
permeate everything as well kind of like
artificial intelligence everything is in
the tons of ways just shrinking in terms
of its size shrinking in terms of its
capacity capabilities and hopefully it's
going to make it easier for us to live
in our in the world yeah I think there's
a bit more than that I think you know
when you can build things that are
closer and closer to what we see in
nature and in biology you can in turn
start a doing the same sorts of amazing
things that biology already does at the
nanoscale but also in turn create things
that are more and more integrated with
biological systems as well yes thank you
one thing that's kind of funny about my
process is that I had this huge issue of
e.coli eating my nanostructures they
were too delicious so it's a very final
compatible I had to start adding
antibiotics or meant that from happening
okay so one so one of the things that I
think you just pointed out that's really
interesting is there's all these
complicated biological processes that
have been
evolving on earth for billions of years
and so now we're kind of looking at the
catalog of biological processes
identifying which ones we want to work
with the kind of like the electronics
era that that we're building and
figuring out how to blend these and
shrink and really give them down in size
and scale but increasing capacity for
applied to our everyday lives
well I think we'll see a blurring of
what we consider technology and what we
consider biology yeah I I there's no
reason that those are distinct things
it's just you know biology happened on
its own but now we are starting to wrest
control over that but then also these
more synthetic approaches like what I've
done as well as what nano fabrication
has done in order to create structures
and understand what we're making and do
it smaller and smaller and have more and
more control and you know at some point
these things might converge you know you
know biology is this amazing way in
which it can have like a code like DNA
and from that it is then able to
generate the huge amounts of complexity
of structure and function that it can in
it you know builds itself right using
that information in turn when we get
enough control over these synthetic
systems you could also imagine building
you know micro machines that can you
know have some embedded code in them
that then allows them to also reproduce
themselves to create again another form
of sort of synthetic evolution or
self-assembly and network into biology
yeah and that's super intelligence no no
no maybe in many ways it feels like it's
all pointing in the direction of super
intelligence I like how you said that
you know we that technology is is part
of biology it's what biology created
technology but it's all together in the
lines of blurring more and more teach us
about digital transcendence and
singularity oh you mean these are pieces
that I made yeah so what it means for ya
yeah well a long time ago right when the
from like analog photography into
digital photography was happening I
thought a lot about mediums and how
mediums have some intrinsic quality to
them it's not that necessarily one is
better all it is is that they're
different you know back then people were
like oh digital that's crap we're gonna
stick with film and darkroom prints are
always better which we've seen is not
really necessarily the case they're
different and they have different
qualities to them and I thought this was
sort of similar to some of the same
thoughts going on in Silicon Valley and
how you know one could upload their mind
to the cloud or perhaps you know
technology becomes a singularity but
that's also a transition into a digital
medium from an analog medium right so I
created these pieces that sort of
question that I came up with a process
by which you can create an image using
light but that image falls apart into
the digital medium it begins to break
apart into these main structures because
the light itself is right on the edge of
what the sensor can sense so it confuses
the algorithms that create that image
that take that information and compose
it into an image and as a results you
end up with this image that is both of
the thing that existed in the analog
world but is now also an image of the
algorithm which then made that
transition into the digital world and I
imagine you know if we end up uploading
our minds for instance you're gonna see
that same sort of transition even if you
can imagine understanding the brain
perfectly up to like 99.9999
9% and you imagine that every you know
microsecond you're doing a computation
if that that last tiny bit if that over
the entire brain just keeps happening
over and over and over again in the
simulation you could very very very
quickly just diverge from being human
for that tiny tiny difference because
over time is the way things function
will just very very quickly change
because the medium with which its
embedded is just oh so slightly
different and that's only if it's also
slightly different it probably would be
very different interesting your thoughts
on mediums I think and the way that
there's a difference between the analog
and the digital and it would and to do
something like be able to upload and
what comes with that process what
fidelity comes with that process it's
complicated it's so hard to even wrap
our minds around what that process like
we don't know what's happening here how
do you even upload that in thinking of
mediums as having some intrinsic
aesthetic and maybe meaning in their own
one of the projects I've started working
on involves thinking about the ocean and
the communication that occurs there
where in the ocean the two primary modes
of communication are sound and light you
see a lot of bioluminescence and you see
a lot of like auditory communication so
I was thinking all right
can we combine these two into a singular
medium for expression and as it turns
out there's these algae that when you
perturb them mechanically they light up
right you can go swimming in these
bioluminescent days and everywhere you
move it lights up around you so the
thought here was you can actually use
waves of sound to mechanically perturb
these algae and cause them to light up
and the cool thing about sound is it's a
wave right so you can actually do
calligraphy with it so you could
potentially even control like how all
the sound waves cancel each other out or
constructively interfere like I was
talking with light earlier to create an
image and
mansions which has been inducing the
emission of light by these of biological
organisms and just trying to use this as
a medium to communicate maybe some of
the more profound struggles that the
ocean is now facing with you know ocean
acidification as well as all the plastic
that's just completely demolishing
ecosystems and that's not to say you
know global warming heating things up is
also taking a huge toll as well so maybe
you know you can have a representation
of that embedded in the mediums of
communication that are intrinsic to the
ocean yeah you have to be able to kind
of see the health bar of what's going on
yeah charli's communicate it and maybe
move people yeah you know move people
into into action yeah yeah so much of
what we do is on that engaging and an
inspiring side of things and and the
work that's that's happening right now
is this place it MIT Media Lab is you
just pop in I mean
well this is just the stuff you see this
is the tip of the iceberg then there's
the rest of MIT which you don't see but
you know a lot of that work is extremely
foundational yeah this is just the stuff
that percolates up into the public eye
hopefully yeah yeah the one that
actually gets talked about through the
media versus the stuff like you said
it's bottle iceberg all of what is you
know happening here as you walk down you
know the halls is you know how much of
these processes are happening in Tel
Aviv or in Shenzhen or in London etc
around the world how many of these you
know groups are working on tackling some
of the the edge of knowledge innovation
well obviously there's people all over
the world working on these problems and
they're all doing fantastic jobs of it
but I think there's something to be said
for concentration when you take enough
minds working on these sorts of problems
and just stick them all in a very closed
space something very special happens
right the serendipity of interaction
takes over and you start seeing people
you know taking disciplines that were
separate and they're just collide to
create something completely new and I
think that's one of the things that the
Media Lab has done a pretty good job of
is taking disparate disparate
disciplines and just just completely
blurring the lines altogether right yeah
it's like yeah it's like when you look
at the edge of knowledge and you find
two fields that's and then where where
is that where did those edges come into
an overt to another vertex and now when
you when you keep pushing when you blur
those lines and keep pushing that edge
then you have all the innovation that
happens in that field that fields emerge
people drink it even in my case like I
took technologies that already exist and
just combined them in a way that nobody
had really thought of because we had
this realization of what the ideal form
of nanofabrication might be and we
surveyed the landscape for what existed
and what we could use and then put them
together and as it turns out that
involved taking elements from by a
biological engineering all the
conjugation chemistry's it involved
taking this new form of microscopy that
edie headed and his students had
invented expansion microscopy as well as
these new ways of doing lithography in
three dimensions which came out of
initially biological imaging but then
started getting applied to nano
fabrication as well so you know no one
of those disciplines on its own could
have done it right it's it's really how
things collide to create something
entirely new yeah you had it yourself as
an experience and you're right you're
putting together the minds at a place
like me alive it's inevitable that you
in such great concentration there's
going to be more and more
I just pushed an an ideas created let's
ask you a couple of the simulation
questions on the way out the first
question is are we in a simulation well
honestly I don't really care whether I'm
in a simulation or not is sort of my
answer it's sort of irrelevant to me if
you're living your life such that when
you find out the simulation is real
you're gonna change then you're probably
living your life wrong if you're content
with what you're doing inside of the
simulation then you'll be great right
does it the whole point is like where
you derive meaning I think one of the
interesting things is today we have like
this crisis of like spirituality or
meaning in our lives largely because a
lot of people have broken away from our
traditional like religious institutions
and things like that which initially had
given us a lot of meaning so now we're
in a place where you know it's very easy
to feel like there is no meaning but
once you take that and you accept that
maybe there is no meaning then the only
meaning that matters is that what you
create for yourself so if you were to
live in a simulation how would you live
your life creating maybe your own
meaning yeah that's a good answer
we we we asked the question a lot to to
proba how people you know think in
general and and that's a it's
interesting that you tie meaning into
the simulation question and and we gain
so much of our fulfillment in our lives
by setting some sort of a of a massive
goal that we want to achieve and you
know taking a burden and going towards
that goal and you know continuing to
level up in the game and then also
potentially making our own simulations
and there's so much other stuff yeah
you'll you know I'm sure media labs are
already deep into simulation territory
and there's going to be a lot more that
that is done not only walk around here
and it's big reminisce and the black
mirror I can tell you that sometime
sometimes there's some positive you know
potentials as well well of course yeah
of course yeah yeah everybody likes to
know there's an image right now on that
screen of a matrix figure yeah yeah that
is ridiculous yeah yeah everybody I know
talking about C's oh so we're in the
matrix and then last question is what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world well I mean my answer is light
that's what I have found you know all
the art I've ever created was you know
for me to like just both communicate as
well as experience the beauty of life
and what can be made from and they
experienced yeah that's the first time
we've heard light as famous yes they're
the most beautiful thing in the world
yeah Wow
yeah for someone that spent you know
decade-plus immersed in it like well I
think one of the ironic things is back
in the days when we worked in the
darkroom in order to create things from
light you had to deprive yourself from
it yeah yeah yeah so I actually spent a
lot of time Andrew
that are completely pitch black in order
to develop film and things like that and
it gives you a very different
appreciation I think for light and you
begin to understand what it means to be
blind also and to have to always have a
map of your entire surroundings in your
head a different kind of simulation yeah
yeah yeah literally a map that the
simulation of what's around you in
three-dimensional space the stylet that
visual without the visual input yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was a really
strong end and it has been such a solid
and enlightening conversation thank you
so much for coming onto the show thank
you for having me
holy cow there's so much work that you
guys are doing here that's fascinating
and had the edge and I'm like a little
child trying to understand and hopefully
help other people get inspired and
engaged with that thank you so much
thanks to everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking about subjects like our tech
light and nanotechnology as well also
find the links below to Dan's work go
and support him support the synthetic
neurobiology group that might see Media
Lab follow them follow their work as
well and support the artists and
entrepreneurs and organizations around
the world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below so you
can do cool things like continue coming
on site and conducting awesome
interviews like this and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace